Dylan Mulvaney likes women now this guy
I'm starting to get to like are you is
he trolling us
is he just trying to make some money off
the [__] I don't know man
oh my God I have never felt so alive I
haven't really talked to you about this
but I have been followed on and off for
the past two months and usually I just
try to pretend it's not happening but
today it really bugged me and I was just
going to get my laser hair removal and I
was like in the office and I like walked
out and I was like I'm gonna lose him
and so I turn full on Fast and Furious
Tokyo Drift and I'm like racing like
down Alleyways and like I felt like Liam
Neeson and like taken and I did it I
lost them it was so exciting but now I
do think I might be addicted to drag
racing and not the RuPaul kind
um but it's also just funny because I
think you know they were trying to get a
picture of me looking not great but I
feel great and I'm just gonna post
post what
it's on here so you know posting it for
free all right happy weekend I love you
protect your piece
I mean that was fine these people in the
thing please get security if you can
yeah but also you know stay safe out
there you know apparently people the
internet is up in arms because Dylan is
saying that
they like uh
women now
or something
so it's like
how how long until
she's just like he she I don't know you
know I I don't want to [__] yeah here
it is
appearance that I may be a little bit
romantically interested in women and
that was a big shock for them
considering the past 10 years of coming
out as gay then queer then non-binary
then trans
and I think it was just a bit of a shock
so I tell my dad and he goes well I
would love to see you get a woman
pregnant and I said oh no no she would
be getting me so I recently told my
parents that I may be a little bit at
the end of it well that's the end of
what I see right here my parents that I
may be a little gone by those
the end of that how does that happen I
think that this person is just uh
[__] with us huh you know what I mean
because it's like uh
I don't know
if the woman got him pregnant or her I
don't I don't even know anymore but if
that person Dylan got pregnant then I'm
in dude just do it get pregnant a person
um and um that's great get pregnant I
wanna I want it to be like I won't be
happy to like to remember that show the
movie Junior was that what it was with
your Arnold schwarza got pregnant or
like Danny DeVito nutted in his [__]
and then he got a well I don't [__]
remember how it goes that's twins but um
ha
yeah Arnold Schwarzenegger got nutted in
but his his butt got nutted in and then
it [__] had a kid
um
yeah
uh
uh the thing is some here's the and I
made a clip on there was a clip that
went viral that I was talking about how
I think this this dilemma veiny person
is not all mentally sound uh and not
because they claim to be trans but
because of how you can tell when
someone's crazy just by looking at them
and even hearing them really
um and I was saying this and then uh
here's another uh red flag on if
somebody is uh not well they are
constantly changing their uh identity
which is that that person is doing that
like this is why a lot of actors are
crazy actors will be like super into Jiu
Jitsu and then yoga and then matcha like
all they know although just eat like
they'll eat vegan and then they'll be
like on a carnivore diet it's like like
Charlie Hunnam probably does that [__]
and he's [__] batshit crazy probably
and uh
I don't know if he does that but I'm
just saying like these people who
constantly change their identity are
[__] insane that's it and I don't
know I'm I don't give a [__] transnot go
ahead B whatever I don't give a [__]
I'm just saying that person sounds like
a loon
not because they're trans
because they sound like a loon I guess
you can be trans
and like women if you were born a guy
it's just all sorts of weird
also what about women dude women are
like man I've been a woman all my life
and it's [__] hard and I gotta deal
with this [__] and get periods and all
that now you're just gonna come along
and be the best woman of all time like
remember when Caitlyn Jenner was on the
cover of the thing women of the year
it's like dude if I was a woman I'd be
so [__] mad
then again who gave a moment of the Year
time or who gives a [__]
you know
honestly gives a [__] about anything
um
is what it is
[Music]
crazy congratulations